one major myth concerns our tradition of
citizen soldiers to fight our Wars a
tradition that began in the colonial era
with every able-bodied male colonist
supposedly ready to grab his trusty
musket off the mantelpiece of his home
and go out to successfully defend his
community beat against Indians or the
French or the Spanish or during the
revolutionary war against the british
now as with most myths this one contains
an element of truth indeed much more
than simply an element during the 17th
century colonists had to rely upon
themselves for defense and they thus
created in the New World from English
tradition the militia system in which
every able-bodied adult male in the
community was a member and liable for
military training on muster days as well
as military service when called up
militia were heavily involved in the
Revolutionary War and the militia system
was enshrined in federal law after the
revolutionary war with the militia act
of 1792 that remained the basic military
legislation for the country until the
early 20th century but in reality the
muster days during the colonial era were
more social events than occasions for
military training and the militia proved
to be an unreliable as well as an
untrained body of soldiers their members
came and went as they pleased and they
are elected or politically appointed
officers wear anything but competent
there were also numerous exemptions from
military service and the system was in a
state of serious decay if not outright
collapse by the time of the
Revolutionary War now the war did
witness a major revival of the militia
system but its members for the most part
remained unreliable and unable to stand
up to British regulars especially a
British bayonet charge Washington
consequently placed little faith in the
militia and instead
focus during the war on the creation and
the rigorous training of his continental
army to fight the British regulars
militia did play a crucial role in
numerous battles and in winning the war
but only when properly led and primarily
in conjunction with the Continental Army
had Washington been able to have his way
little reliance would have been placed
on militia after the war but realizing
that would be politically impossible as
well as ideologically and practically
impossible Washington called for a
system whereby the central government
would control the militia and impose
uniformity on it in terms of arms
organization and training but that
proved to be equally impossible
consequently a dual defense system
emerged under the Constitution it
consisted of a small professional army
and the state militia with authority
over state militia split between the
national and state governments but with
the passage of the militia act of 1792
what that actually translated into was
no centralized control and no uniformity
all males aged 18 to 45 were required by
this act to enroll in the militia but
there was no federal control over
training arms or officer selection
primary reliance was thus placed not on
the militia but on a small professional
army augmented by volunteers in times of
war as well as a draft during the Civil
War and on special elite volunteer
militia units that had begun to form in
the colonial era these gradually evolved
during the late 19th century into the
present day national guard now militia
units were used during the 19th century
usually with disappointing results they
did very poorly during the War of 1812
and they'll they're lawless behavior
during the war with Mexico was so
outrageous that the Mexicans label them
quote bandits vomited from hell
regular officers concurred and there was
little love lost between militia and the
Regular Army indeed Regular Army
reformers consistently called for either
an end to the militia system or strong
federal control over it the National
Guard did come under greater federal
control during the 20th century but
during the two world wars in the Cold
War primary reliance for manpower was
placed upon a national draft a system of
universal military training was proposed
but it never passed consequently we
retain today the dual system of a
regular army and elite volunteer militia
units but that is not the citizen
soldier concept of universal military
obligation and service that as well as
the belief that untrained or poorly
trained citizens can defeat regulars is
part of our national mythology
you